[Music]  in azerbaijan's capital baku rebellious  underground poets regularly gather in  taverns and pubs to fight but these  poets don't use their fists  they throw punches with rhythms and  rhymes  this is mekana  this great big story is made possible by  azerbaijan tourism  [Music]  is a traditional mix of poetry and song  performed in the form of a freestyle and  improvised verbal face-off  [Music]  is always improvised it's traditionally  performed to the beat of a drum or  simple finger clicking  there's no room for even the tiniest  moment of hesitation because without  music there's nothing to fill any gaps  or silences so mekana poets have to  chime in the second their opponent has  finished  30 years his success has earned him the  title of a master but he still has one  wish  [Music]  order  [Music]  is  [Music]  you